i knew oj for me the key of him is his
connection with the horses they're his
friends like genuinely his friends and
so i knew i had to understand animal
life at a different level he grieved
with the horses
there is a truth there like horses
how spiritual i mean they have
personalities that's why i had to like
see how he sees
himself through his friends
i love how silent he is i go silent a
lot
i love seeing that on screen just a man
thinking a man in his self
emerald haywood is that character that
doesn't really have a lot going on like
that
she's got charisma she knows how to talk
to people but she doesn't really have a
lot of discipline and she really doesn't
know a clear direction of where she's
going she also really loves her family
but has a very interesting relationship
with them i think she's at that
crossroad phase that many of us have
gone through where we kind of hate going
back home because it reminds us of who
we were and that's not who we are and we
kind of don't know if we feel good about
that or not she got the personality of
her dad
while oj didn't
she's like a natural successor in terms
of her energy her personality but
oj is the one that stayed you know it's
just like innate love there
which is i find the most exciting thing
about this film showing a brother sister
being friends you know saying being real
you